Lissie thank you for doing this it's
really nice of you no problem I had
literally nothing else to do
oh that's right you're in quarantine
right and for some reason are you in a
stand-up comedy club where is this brick
wall coming from is this your apartment
bunker bunker very high blew it
I know I've known you for years and
you've always said I've got to go I'm
working on my quarantine bunker and I
always thought Lizzie what I don't think
that's gonna be a problem who's laughing
now you did it you did it
congratulations it looks beautiful brick
by brick Memphis it's gorgeous
let me explain to everyone who's
watching right now that you are in
London and so and I want to make that
very clear because just before we
started I forgot for a second that you
were in London and you're in a
completely different time zone it's
evening where you are just before we
started I saw you take a nice sip of
some white wine and I thought oh wait a
minute it's 9:20 in the morning that's
not good and then I realized no what
you're doing is fine the fact that I
just had some white wine at 9:30 in the
morning is a problem so all bets are off
at this point it's forgive yourself do
whatever you need to do to get by and
for the record it's actually an orange
one much here oh my god it looks very
sophisticated thank you no it's your
it's your bumpers okay so you're in a
bunker and you're drinking your urine
that's yeah great what a lovely way to
start the interview can I just ask you
really quickly I'm just curious
I'm experiencing this in Los Angeles so
I have some sense of I mean there's so
many different experiences in America
but I have this feeling that right now
in England they have that famous stiff
upper lip as do you think that's is that
true or is that just a cliche I feel
like you'd be much
you guys would be handling it like it's
the Blitz oh it's so and nothing will
get through this and people walking
around with umbrellas and not caring
yeah it's served them the English people
very well during the Blitz and kind of
throughout history I actually have a lot
of respect for this but no it feels a
bit like back home I assume most of us
are doing what we're supposed to do and
then there's like a handful of [ __ ]
that feel like they really need to get
out to the park and drink and public and
and and cough a lot and people oh the
ones that are outside without a mask
always coughing yes yeah yeah we're
having that too here in LA they just
opened they're like they didn't even
open the beaches and people just decided
tens of thousands of people said yeah
this isn't cool anymore it was kind of
cool to being quarantined for bit but
I'm bored with it now we're all going to
the beach and we're gonna lick each
other I know I know
it's really it makes me very mad I've
become I'm definitely like following the
rules in a really hardcore way which is
kind of a new thing for me
but I don't want to do this for two
years so just don't go to the beach like
it's not that bad if you're not a health
worker or an essential worker of any
kind like it's not that just stay in
your house watch TV or else we're gonna
be doing this forever yeah by the way I
consider myself an essential worker how
do you you know I mean they say comedies
the best medicine I've seen no proof of
that it's actually it's a terrible
medicine